bonsoir jean paul stahl merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
pour commencer
quelles sont ces personnels qui sont
exclus de cette revalorisation salariale
prévue par les accords du ségur de la
santé alors je m'avancerai peut-être un
petit peu parce que je ne suis pas
syndicaliste et j'ai encore moins
participer aux discussions du ségur
cependant à ma connaissance c'est plutôt
les personnels qui ne sont pas dis très
directement liés aux soins ou tout au
moins et qui a un accès à qui on a une
fonction de soins assez indirects alors
que ça ne peut pas dire que ces
personnes ne n'ont pas travaillé pendant
la période bien entendu justement quel
regard vous portez vous sur cette
différence de traitement
c'est vrai que ça à partir du moment où
on accorde à rosas il faut une
justification extrêmement forte pour ne
pas accorder aux autres à partir de et
dans un hôpital les fonctions sont quand
même très mêler les unes aux autres et
très complémentaires les unes des autres
donc il est vrai que faire les
différences de sept ans ça peut être
assez mal vécue et être assimilé à une
forme d'injustice est justement quelle
est la situation est l'ambiance au sein
de votre chu de grenoble alpes par
exemple à ce que cette différence de
traitement se fait ressentir au
quotidien par une baisse de motivation
notamment chez les personnes concernées
non honnêtement non les personnels
hospitaliers les eei savent très bien
différencier d'un côté ce qui est
strictement professionnels le soin aux
ballades et puis de l'autre côté ce qui
est une revendication syndicale on va
dire la meilleure preuve c'est quand ils
font grève ils mettent en grève sur le
dos de leurs blouses mais il travaille
c'est pas tout à fait le lot commun
donc il ya vraiment une différence entre
les deux est le soin actuellement n'est
absolument pas perturbé par ce genre de
chose par contre le
l'idée qu'on se fait du de
l'administration au sens très large est
impactée effectivement par ce genre de
choses
en quoi est-ce important que jean castex
soit attentif à ce courrier des hôpitaux
publics on pourrait éventuellement
assister à de nouvelles démissions comme
on l'a vu ces derniers mois
non d'abord les démissions sont assez
marginal honnêtement même si ça existe
c'est assez marginal non ces tunnels
c'est une question de gouvernance au
sens très large du terme de l'hôpital
public l'hôpital public depuis 20 ans
est de plus en plus appauvris à la fois
dans les personnels dans le nombre de
personnel à la fois dans l'absence de
revalorisation des des métiers qui sont
les moins bien payés et puis il est mal
lotie dans la gouvernance c'est-à-dire
qu'on a petit à petit fait glisser
l'hôpital public paiera une logique
industrielle
au lieu de rester dans une logique
médicale et donc tout ça mais l'effet
que l'ambiance est mauvaise et les
revendications peuvent être exacerbée
par ce genre de choses dans pau apps
apaiser le climat
effectivement ce type de mesures telles
qu'elles viennent d'être annoncées sont
certainement des bonnes choses c'est pas
les seuls mais c'est certainement une
bonne chose
et pour que ces personnels hospitaliers
qui n'ont pas eu le droit 7 à cette
augmentation puissent en bénéficier
quels sont les leviers que l'hôpital
public pourrait actionner
dans le cas où le goût le ce courrier
restent sans réponse de l'exécutif
je sais par féret il faudrait voir avec
les syndicats la façon dont ils
imaginent des choses mais j'ai du mal à
imaginer que dans la période actuelle
les responsables au niveau du
gouvernement n'entend pas ce genre de
ce genre de demande je parle pas de
récriminations parce que ça c'est pas le
mot mais ce genre de demande
je m'imagine mal qu'ils ne craignaient
répand casas qui ne répondent pas à ça
parce que la situation aujourd'hui vous
vous en parliez et délicate dans les
hôpitaux aujourd'hui comment ça se passe
à grenoble par exemple
la situation est extrêmement tendue dans
l'est dans les hôpitaux
elle est extrêmement tendue dans notre
dans notre hôpital on n'est pas encore
en situation de débordement des
capacités d'accueil mais on s'en
approche et comme les bonnes nouvelles
sont toujours décalée de 15 jours dans
un rapide dans l'hôpital c'est à dire
que le second pense voir en ce moment
une espèce de stabilisation du nombre de
cas pour nous elle ne sera visible que
dans quinze jours c'est à dire pendant
quinze jours l'écart augmenté c'est vrai
qu'il ya une tension et professionnels
une tension du soin qui est extrêmement
extrêmement importante
merci beaucoup jean paul stahl d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes infectiologues au chu grenoble
alpes